I started another caption contest at the
beginning of the new year and we've got
some pretty cool captions about this
photo you see our late great sassy cat
as she was so often doing sitting in my
lap actually standing on my lap and I
just happened to have a nice meatball
sandwich with you know the sauce and
onions and tomatoes that I was getting
ready to eat and Sassy decided that she
wanted a Sniff and then a lick and then
perhaps even a bit of the meatball she's
not interested in the vegetables or the
bread she knows where the good stuff is
so let's see the things that people had
to say about this first we had a couple
that were very punny you know you see
three of them here all mine you got to
be kitten me and then sassy with a
Chance of Meatballs you know uh forget
exactly what the film was that had a
Chance of Meatballs but there's there's
a good quip there and then one that's a
little bit more philosophically inclined
but yet still relying entirely on a pun
confessions of the flesh Michael Foo cat
instead of food cause that's kind of
good then we had I think it proved
rather irresistible to people to start
conversing in a stereotypical a rather
stereotyped Italian way so one says and
I'm not going to try doing this in an
Italian accent my salmon meatball tastes
like a salami meatball and of course
there's a lot packed into that joke
right the cats can have a little salami
As a treat and of course the meatballs
were just plain old beef with the other
things that I put in them so not salmon
not salami but you know pretty good joke
at someone a spicy meat to ball Lots is
in there and it kind of makes sense it
wasn't really that spicy or she wouldn't
be eating it and then there was That's
Amore you know when the moon hits your
eye like a big pizza pie so no meatballs
in that actual song I think but it's
redolent of Italiana I suppose so then
we get some things that are directly
philosophically referencing something
here's one it seems the slave has left
the master a dialectical treat I suppose
in that case I'm supposed to be the
slave and Sassy the cat is the master uh
dialectical doing a lot of work there I
suppose the next one if you gaze into
the sausage it gazes back into you
there's no sausage on that but sausage
is pretty close to meatball in terms of
sandwiches and sauces and stuff like
that I suppose there's a nature
reference of course to the void that if
you gaze into to it it gazes back at you
here's one that doesn't make a reference
to a popular philosophical line or to a
philosopher but it's I think it's
actually on track it is not in temperate
if the meat smells this good yeah can a
cat have Temperance that's debatable but
perhaps there have to be exceptions for
the virtues in order for them to be
adequate to our lives here's another one
and with this we enter into what I would
call the realm of cat logic taking it
from the last line of this one is cat
brain calculating one side says just
give it a try smells okay other side
don't do it nothing good will come of it
back to side one but it smells so good I
am cautiously going for it cat logic at
its finest now sassy was the sword who
had inclined to the first sentence I
think not so much about being cautious
here's the the second one and this is a
very funny one memory respects premise a
cute cats deserve love from humans
premise B humans deserve a tasty
breakfast claim cute cats deserve a
tasty breakfast valid argument no
clearly not a valid argument and nobody
should think that it is there's a lot
going on in there right and it's kind of
funny too because if it was a valid
argument which is not it probably
wouldn't be a sound argument you know
talking about the tasty breakfast
because this isn't a breakfast at all
but it is kind of funny to see somebody
trying to put it into syllogistic form
and then we get some more cat logic here
as well this one is a little bit more
straightforward you eat this luxury and
give me those cat treats instead come on
you got to be kidding me now the irony
here is that Sassy actually got pretty
high-end cat treats you know all sorts
of good stuff of different tastes and
coming from different animals and
various flavors but she also really did
like to be offered at least offered a
taste of any sort of meat product that
we had and then she would decide for
herself whether she wanted some of it uh
here's another one I don't know exactly
how you would classify this one but it's
uh it's kind of funny I said no tomatoes
Greg not give me all the tomatoes you
have no no no it's fine I'll just lick
around them geez aren't you a professor
or something and you notice if you go
back to the picture it not only has
Tomatoes but also onions so she I
suppose could have complained about that
we finish up with one that actually made
my wife laugh which is a one line really
really good joke right here meat cute
cute cat we've got meat in the picture
and of course a meat cute is when you've
got people together and ROM comes and
the closest things that you would find
to that in the life of cats that aren't
you know looking to mate or anything
would probably be like this a cat and a
sandwich that they're attracted to if
you want to get in on these I post
caption contests every once in a while
in my community tab you'll probably want
to turn on your notifications that's the
Bell that you can turn on on my YouTube
channel if you're following that way you
get alerted when I do these and we've
got plenty that we've done already that
you can go back to and we'll do plenty
more in the future because uh which keep
taking more and more pictures so if you
want to get in on it you know what you
need to do